Kyrie Irving said he missed out on 100  million plus dollars because of his  decision to not get vaccinated against  coven 19. Kyrie said he felt the Nets  gave him an ultimatum with two options  he said they offered him a four-year  100-something million dollar contract if  he got vaccinated or he doesn't get  vaccinated and his future is uncertain  in the league Kyrie said he had to deal  with real life circumstances that he  could lose his job Nets GM Sean Mark  said there is no ultimatum offered and  that he stands by Kyrie Mark said the  Nets want people who are reliable and  accountable but he added that no one  should feel forced to get vaccinated  Kyrie will end the season as an  unrestricted free earning the last 36.5  million of his current contract